hey guys dr. Burke here in this short
video we're going to talk about the
amazing health benefits of consuming
beets now it is true that beets are
higher in sugar but in the fiber that
they have as a whole unit if you were to
shred them on your salad I think that
would be okay okay it's not going to be
that big of a deal so what I like to do
is I like to take the tops off the beets
first wash them and freeze them and I
use those in like in my kale shake I'll
mix kale parsley with beet tops and I'll
add a little bit of berries blend it up
and oh my gosh that will really help
help your liver okay so that's one thing
then the actual beat itself you can
shave them in your salad I like to get
different color beets I'll get the
purple beet
I'll get the yellow beet I'll get the
red beet and I'll just use them and I
just love them so these are the benefits
there's something in your liver that
allows toxins to be turned into harmless
particles so basically the liver has
certain enzymes to break down chemicals
okay and the beets improve that process
to the point where it helps you detoxify
chemicals in the liver so it's really
good and liver beets also are high in
antioxidants they're high in choline
they're high in certain nutrients that
dissolve fat on your inside your liver
so if you have a fatty liver you want to
consume beets okay so they have a lot of
great properties to fix the liver and
the gallbladder they will improve the
exits estrogen the liver and also
indirectly raised some testosterone
levels to balance it out it won't give
you too much testosterone but it
balances out to a normal level because
to testosterone works with the liver so
it's a really good hormonal balancer so
it will decrease estrogen and increase
testosterone giving you better workouts
more endurance more
stamina okay blood pressure really good
too it has nitric oxide which relaxes
the arteries in the cardiovascular
system to lower blood pressure it's
another good benefit right and it's good
anti-inflammatory so again start using
these on your salad in your shakes and
it's going to really provide some really
cool benefits to your your body and also
click the link below I have a quiz down
there you can take that will allow you
to find out what's really going on with
your body and will send you the report
thanks for watching